do you think that this weed is good
enough for your papers most certainly do
I wish I don't like an Apple TV's know
much elsewhere
you don't know what the you're
missing what's up well she played a
partner checking in to China and you
know me I'm flamboyant I like the fancy
thing and I'm always craving for
something more this is the new season of
the most expensive this let's get
into it
yo what you got going on right here I
got for you right here is the world's
more luxurious and most expensive
rolling paper made out of 24 karat
edible gold plating process is handmade
it has a distinctive taste coz we're
smoking to go inside because I ate gold
time you're not really smoking the gold
what you're smoking is underneath and
around the gold so all you have left
over is gold - we have sheets - for 20
and then we have these 12 pack of around
55 does it come with we know how about
we put our most expensive meals with
your most expensive roller paper and
have an expensive experience do it well
I just so happened to a brat the world's
most expensive cannabis what you got now
we have the top shelf and the isla which
are canned cannabis this is actually cut
off the plant and they trim it they put
it in here they seal it and they cure it
in the cannon this year mom hadn't been
a saucer days and how much are these in
a camp it's just a hundred dollars again
oh this sure this would be $800 an
ounce this is like the Lay's potato
chips here open up new kitchen there's
only four on the inside oh I'm by the
smoking most expensive John cause you
got that tender a hunt down
carrot one whoa again mm-hmm I just want
to win on y'all to do that I could pull
out Z secret weapon oh this is the
biggest pipe in the world just start to
Deena put an ounce allowed in here I'm
gonna trade you okay
beautiful joint funky feel tip it
[Music]
interesting you do taste it a little bit
you tell you go it's the gold go pay
this real gold bro
24k so uh go like get the fans or a bar
and it really holds the ashes I see what
you're saying how do I get it to do that
they have to know somebody to do that
this is like the caviar of joints you
know what I'm saying the most expensive
is John I'm smoking the most expensive
in China in the world this was one
experience that I would never forget
this is one for the record books I don't
even know how I wrap this up brother are
you too high to wrap this up no no this
wrap up another joint that's what we're
gonna do we're gonna get out of here now
you're gonna get out of here now
we're gonna stay right here hard-working
dedication you could be right
so yeah $800 ounce if we go wrapping
paper talking about being flamboyant it
was almost so fancy you didn't even want
to smoke your butt you know me
that as you saw it though man I was
hard to handle that big-ass pipe most
expensive his pipe but the most
expensive is weed the most expensive is
paper I will be doing that again
[Music]